مثل ما يقولون كل ادب يحب ان تؤتى مادبته
مادبه الله القران فالله سبحانه وتعالى
ينادي الناس يريد الناس في المسجد عشان
ينالوا من هذه الماده خير فانت جيت تنادي
قلت عارف الصلاه تعالوا الفلاح تعالوا الى
كريم يعطيكم كل شيء يقول يا رب ترا فلان
فلاني والله سمعته ذاك اليوم وقال اشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد مسلم وموحد بسم
الله
ابراهيم بن جمعان بن علي الزهراني
مؤذن اول ما بدات تقريبا في مسجد جامع جنب
بيتنا
كان ابوي اخذنا مع الجمعه
كنت اروح معه فجاه يناديني بابراهيم
اسوي
اني اتحاش يعني فوقف كذا بين دور وين وين
ابراهيم توم قال لي
باذن الجمعه
[موسيقى]
يعني الحين الجمعه
رحت سلام عليكم ممكن اذن
المؤذن اصعب شيء عنده اللي هو تنظيم الوقت
المفروض يكون اكثر واحد واكثر منظم
واحيانا الوظيفه تكون وظيفتك مثلا الى
ثنتين الظهر او الى ثلاثه يقول لك نص ساعه
في الطريق نص ساعه تصلي
من البريك حقك حتى في ترتيب مواعيده يعني
ما عنده شي اسمه اقابلك بعد المغرب من
المغرب يعيش هذا وقت ياه في البيت ما تقدر
انك تروح مكان ثاني
تحديدا يصير ما نقول كنا خطابه بس في دور
في
جمع الروس بالحلال فيتصلون دائما كثير
السلام عليكم معك فلاني ابي اتاكد من فلان
اذا يصلي معكم ولا لا
المؤذن بعد الصلاه يصير الجماعه في ظهره
الامام لا يلتفت يشوف الناس كلهم فالامام
اقدر في هذا في الناس
يسولوني يقول لي ارسلي صوره يقول لي
تعرفها ولا ما اعرفها
المسجد ابدا
يصير
في الزواج
اللي بعده تعرف هذا لا والله ما اعرفه
خلاص يا جماعه
مثلا العصر والله ناس راجع من الدوام نايم
واللي فاتح اتصالات فاعطاها اذان حزين
المغرب والله الناس مروقه متقهوره كذا
فحطهم مكه مثلا
العشاء هذه الصلاه
في واحد من الجماعه المسجد
مو بس يعرف اني متضايق ولا فرحان لا حتى
مثلا
اذا مثلا وديت المدام ورجعت في السفر
يقول له السلام عليكم
اذا في نوم
زين والله ماني زين يحب العجم ده حجازي
اذا انت اذاني انه يحبه واحد الجماعه حيث
الصوت في الواتس او انت ابو بدر
واحد من جماعه المسجد
امه تنام عند الشباك
فيقول ايضا
من جانب ديني عاد ما ادري بس على كلام
كثير من العلم ان المؤذن افضل عند الناس
لا المؤذن اقل يعني مكانه ايا كان وهذا لا
ينقص من قدره في الاخير الله سبحانه يعلم
ان هذا افضل وهذا افضل سواء كان مؤذن امام
حارس مسجد ايا كان غير ان الامام له وجهه
عيون الناس كل شيء سولف
تبسطون مع اكثر ما يتوسطون مع الامام عاده
يعني فالناس ما يتوجهون مثلا بالاسئله
بالكلام عاده يعني فيما يتعلق باهتماماتهم
الدينيه خل نقول يعني سولف
[موسيقى]
علاقتي بالموضوع
كان مره
ماني قادر الحق الاذان وطالع متاخر وطاير
زحمه انا هنا توترت ولا في احد ما عندي
نائب والامام الظاهر ما كان موجود حتى
بيروح وقته ولازم يرفع الاذان المسجد كبير
وفي وسط حقيقي كبير واعلى اعلى اعلى صوت
في الحياه تقريبا فكلمت الحارس قلت له اذن
ممكن
ياذن انا شغلته
ذكي فشغلت الكاميرا بشوف اذانا
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر يمكن 9 مرات
انا هنا قلت هذي الطعمه
الجماعه الان بيستلموني ويدقون علي المكتب
الوزاره شكوى وش الاذان اليمنى نزل تسع
مرات تتكبر
في واحد من جماعه مسجد هذا ابد فخذ بفخذه
كل صلاه قال قبل ما شاء الله تبارك الرحمن
واكبر مدافع عن المؤذن واذا مثلا اذنت يجي
واحد يجي مكاني او من بعد الاذان او قبل
الاقامه يجي واحد
ابو خالد ارجع رجعه وراهشه وكذا
الظهر اكيد الدوام ما جاء العصر ما جاء
المغرب دخلت انا اذن والاقي وانا داخل
المسجد من قدام ولده داخل وراح من الجماعه
كلمه وشوف هذا وانا
رجال مختلف جيت
وخلصت جاني قال لي عرفتني ولد ابو خالد
ولا
ابو خالد
وانا كل صلاح جنبي انا مقاول ضاقت بي
الدنيا
فكره ان الاذان المزعج في في امرين في
عنده نوع عنده نوع من الانزعاج يعني هو ما
يتحمل الصوت او عنده مرض واحد مريض
العائله عنده كبير في السن يخاف عنده طفل
عنده توحد فيخاف من الصوت يطلب من المسجد
انه يحولون ثم ينزلون هذا ما في مشكله بس
خبيثه صحيح وانا اظن الله اعلم ان كثير من
الناس من هذا الجانب
اللي هو انه لا يريد يسمع الاذان ليش لانه
يذكره بشيء هو لا يريده في ناس وفعلا بس
كون عنده دافع ديني معين يقول لا حتى مزعج
حتى مزعجني انا ابيه كثير ناس يقول والله
كنت بسوي شيء
معين فدخلت الاذان فيجيه واعظ داخلي يا
اخي شلون نسوي كذا ما يصلح فهو يبي يميت
هذا يميت هذا الوعظ اللي في نفسه يعني من
مقاصد الاذان اولا اعلاء كلمه الله سبحانه
وتعالى في الارض واعلام بدخول الوقت وايضا
واعظ الناس
تسمع الاذان فجاه واحد تلاقي ناس مسجد بس
مروه هو مشغل اغاني
بعد ما يتعدى ليش انه ذكره ما يبغى يتذكر
ابدا فيبغى يميت كل مظهر المظاهر اللي
يتذكره بانه ما يصلح ما يجوز
شكرا
عشان المفضل يعني اذا لاني اشد لك مثلا حي
في الرياض
اذا صرت موظف في الحرم مكه الحرم المدينه
تحدك الدنيا وما فيها يشد لك واحد يوم من
فرنسا واحد من توجو واحد من الكاميرون
[موسيقى]
اشهد
ان لا اله الا الله